so that means that the very top honors
in the documentary category this year go
to director David aristizabal with his
film a second chance I'm sorry I have to
read because English is not my native
language in well I i would like to thank
my I mean all the cool who is he I mean
some of them are here could you please
stand up drew diamond and Josh she
producers guild show DP they low-balled
composer might shoot and Eddie in sound
and Jeff Chan Lee and Mark manado
editors I mean they did like an
incredible job and I really i mean i
mean everything that's there I mean I of
them to them for their I mean awesome
job and talent and work I also would
like to thank my faculty Lisa Lehman
Josh Martin Richard burr Richard Burton
kada man and very special thank you to
my mentors I'm on the Pope and Mark
Harris I also would like to thank Eric
Talia's Giles Clarke Johanna Demetrius
and Alan Holtzman well and I also would
like to thank Laura che hanno gitsune
she was like my lucky charm for this
whole process and finally I need to I
mean like most and special thank you I
mean to my family I mean there came all
the way here from Colombia and muchas
gracias who said todo lo que soy el
sello 0 stairs
and finally mostly special thank you
again to Clarissa black pets for vets
she's the founder of marvelous and I
foundation who's risking dogs and like
so she can give them to veterans for
almost about to commit suicide and so
she's saving lives also David Harlan to
inviting us to his home and sharing his
experiences with us and especially blade
and Anthony who really opened his heart
and soul and who really wanted to be
here but he's really sick he's really
ill he couldn't come hopefully he gets
the care he he deserves thank you very
much